you all know my feelings about Donald
Trump I think he's a complete and total
doofus dangerous wannabe authoritarian
dictator liar con man grifter you all
know that
the DeSantis campaign launch was so bad
that it made Donald Trump's memes and
posts to truth social
actually make Trump seem like a funny
and clever guy and a couple people wrote
to me and said wow your brain is so
broken David that now you think Trump
looks good you know the same people who
are saying you're too critical of trump
you're you have Trump derangement
syndrome are now telling me I'm deranged
because I think that the DeSantis event
made Trump look better Trump's campaign
now looks like it is functioning
properly that's how bad the DeSantis
launch was Trump posted this video to
Troth Central and it's a contrasting
video of Trump's launch and the DeSantis
launch it's genuinely funny take a look
at this take a listen to this and you'll
see when you hear the country song
it's Trump's campaign launch and then
when you hear audio feedback loops it's
the DeSantis Twitter spaces launch this
is genuinely funny here we go
[Applause]
we are kind of melting the servers
ing his mouth
stand up
have uh Governor Sanders uh make us up
okay so what is amazing about this is
there are levels of things there are
levels of disasters when we many of us a
couple a few 20 000 of us or so watch
the Trump campaign announcement together
we did a live stream Beautiful live
stream some say the best
and when Trump comes out and he's all
stiff and he's standing there hinging
back and forth and leaning forward and
God bless the USA is playing and a crowd
of Mar-A-Lago sycophants is almost you
know peeing their pants in in titillated
pleasure over the presence of Donald
Trump we look at it and we say this is a
humiliation how it after all these years
dating back to 2015 this disastrous
Trump campaign blah blah all this stuff
how are these people this is this is
humiliating and Trump looks like a more
what could possibly be worse than this
and then what's worse is DeSantis tries
to announce his candidacy on Twitter
spaces and it goes horribly wrong by the
time it starts 25 minutes late due to a
technical disaster DeSantis just talks
about woke woke woke reading a prepared
speech on Twitter and you realize wow
the Trump event was the previous bottom
of the barrel but DeSantis is far far
far worse and now we go well the Trump
event I guess wasn't that bad now
meanwhile over on Truth social Trump
really getting a lot of mileage out of
this and it'll be interesting to see
where the polling goes as a result of
this Fiasco Trump posting to truth quote
Rob my red button so he calls Ron
DeSantis Rob now I don't even know where
that comes from Rob my red button is
bigger better stronger and is working
truth yours does not per my conversation
with Kim Jong-un of North Korea soon to
become my friend then continuing wow the
Des Sanctus Twitter launch is a disaster
his whole campaign will be a disaster
watch Trump continuing this genuinely is
funny uh Tim Scott's presidential launch
even with the broken microphone phone
don't pay the contractor Tim was by far
the best presidential launch of the week
robs was a catastrophe and then lastly
Trump trophing is the DeSantis launch
fatal yes so a self-inflicted error for
sure
later on in the evening desant
disappeared on Fox News to talk policy
and that was a disaster we'll talk later
but but but but before we assume too
much
DeSantis continues to gain in the polls
against Trump
since news of the announcement broke
what you see on the screen the purple
line is Trump and the green line is
DeSantis as you can see starting in late
March when news of Trump's arrest went
public it was just up up up for Trump
going from 44 to 56 in the Republican
primary and DeSantis falling from a high
of 30 all the way down to 19. but
but since news broke that DeSantis would
be announcing DeSantis climbing from 19
to 21 and Trump dropping from 56 to 54.
is it a big change no
but is it an inflection point is Maga
going to abandon Trump are we going to
see this is the inevitable rise of Ron
DeSantis we have to wait and see after
the break we will look at desantis's
first major interview as a 2024
presidential candidate and I will warn
you it is tough to watch remember that
Monday Memorial Day now just a few days
away we will be offering a one-day
membership special this is our end of
May launch 2024
discounted membership special one day
only if you'd like to be notified of how
to sign up for a criminally inexpensive
membership on Monday
simply get on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com we'll take a quick
break it is a hell of a program today
are you tired of getting crushed in the
market or the volatility there is some
good news which is that treasury yields
are surging you can now get a whopping
five percent yield on treasury bills
that is higher than any high yield
savings account that I have seen but
buying U.S treasuries can be a
complicated process at least it used to
be that's where our sponsor public.com
comes in with public you can buy
treasury bills in seconds right from
your phone couldn't be easier plus
public will even automatically roll over
your Investments at maturity so you have
one less thing to think about take
another thing off your plate treasury
bills are government-backed securities
considered one of the safest Investments
out there and when you buy them through
public they are securely stored at the
Bank of New York Mellon which is the
largest custodian Bank in the world no
minimum hold periods no settlement
delays you have full access to your
funds whenever you need them put your
cash to work earn at five percent yield
by going to public.com Pacman don't miss
the opportunity the link is down below